presentations for every team that joins
the hackathon every team got a body
they're all lined up over here and
there's a little indoor navigation
course that they're going to try to
complete we'll follow you guys we'll
follow with the live stream so you guys
can follow along
and uh start by handing over to the
first presenters
hey Harold no one's in yet maybe we
should wait we give them like 30 seconds
took a move over to this one oh yeah
do you want me to uh
uh maybe you can reply to the Twitter we
got our first person
okay
yeah but I mean if you want to watch
live live streams I mean we have 40 in
the other one too
yeah
[Music]
no it's only unable to create stream
all right I'll just delete your
announcement and okay do another one
sounds good
all right the people are starting to
roll in let's give them like maybe 30
seconds
what's Twitter
foreign
right here guys right here I'm joining
the live stream
are you in there
[Laughter]
right ready
yeah
all right so I guess we're a team
is this our team name yeah okay
uh initially I wanted to hear lung
control but that
is pretty hard so you'll see what I
gotta try doing that later but then
we're like okay I might as well
just try to do a complete end to end so
we start running around with the comma
body on the stick and then getting a
video of when you have to turn left
right and go straight
and then
uh yeah basically just try to get that
to work
so there's some latent space painting
yeah yeah the this technique can best be
described as painting the way in space
where we we walk around and we
essentially tell it at every point
and has to be completely manually
labeled and for every single
for every new environment or lighting
changing new data another thing it's the
one downside
but we did manage to get it at least
running from here to the back corner and
then from the back corner to the outside
and do the loop but we have not gotten
about to work in series so I think we're
just gonna do the first half today uh
yeah I've got this video of
yeah great artists deal the first person
uh
yeah
oh yeah we have a video I guess we'll
show the video at the end because it's
not gonna work right now
so this is like
about 10 minutes of just running around
trying to paint the light in space that
the directions
I think we'll jump into this demo and uh
disclaimer is I don't actually know if
this is the model that worked I don't
know one time that we were able to get
this to work so
Harold I think we should do an overview
of what the course actually is first
I think none of the people on the stream
have seen this oh yeah maybe
they run with the streamers yeah let's
do a walk through first yeah let's do it
and then you want to redo your intro I
know a lot of people joined after yeah
yeah
so let's just walk through the course
here
so we start somewhere in our office
and it's a small indoor navigation
challenge so the bodies have to navigate
through this hallway
go all the way through all the way to
the end as you can see the first part is
just straight so it's not that much of a
challenge but there's a there's a
gradient that becomes harder and harder
as you turn
now we see the narrowing doorways
um yeah so every team that came to the
hackathon was provided with the body and
over the last you know 48 hours or
something like that
a little bit
to go outside you go over these ramps
over here so you still got smooth
Terrain
and then the challenge really starts to
ramp up a lot of the teams had
difficulty here with the changing
lighting conditions
throughout the day and night
so we gotta turn around
turn around the traffic cone and then
finally this is the end of the course
so if any team succeeds this is uh what
you'll see them do
and I guess we'll head back in for the
demo of the first guys
yes all right it seems like we lost the
stream there for a second outside but
basically
you just have to uh head out go run some
cone
and end on an x on the ground
and that's it
all right we'll be back here in a second
see the first attempt of uh Luigi trying
to do this course
the Deep you want to take back this
stream
it's okay are we ready for our first try
okay
let's see how nervous I guess
all right pretty good Stars pretty good
so
um
we should uh
is it gonna recover
oh
hopefully I guess right
no no no no no oh no that's the light is
it gonna cover
oh it could it does want to go to the
right
let's get in there let's get in there so
much noise
it's gonna get there it's gonna get
there
oh my God come on Luigi
oh
he knows where to go though that's the
important part it's not backing up
enough yeah just like FSD
that's so close
[Music]
it's like one inch
oh
that's all right
all right we're back
so that was Luigi
from the church event to end I did it
oh so you still trying
oh
it's like stuck again it's stuck again
oh I don't think it'll work faster that
was anticlimactic
this needs 10 more tries no it is it's
gonna do it this time
yeah we got it to back up more than this
use it to increase your backup time it
didn't make a difference
all right last one
no
I don't think it'll go much better than
this all right let's call it this was
before the outdoor data
all right let's see the next contestant
for the other the other
no no we ended that run
yeah
what is this
they might be carrying it yeah they're
helping it yeah I think let's move on
that was Luigi oh yeah it's a bit of a
bit of an intro for new people 48.
48 we're all the people
[Laughter]
[Music]
they're asking if you're asleep
one morning right now it's earlier the
time okay uh so this is kind of hack
four
um I didn't do anything I just showed up
I'm kind of a participant uh these are
the bodies uh you can buy them in the
comic shop uh they're all topped by
beautiful comma 3 X's also available at
the comma shop almost not even on
backorder anymore uh these things can do
things for the first time in history we
were too ambitious when we first
launched the Biomat when we first
launched the body we thought it was
going to balance on two wheels that was
too much now it has training units and
it's much more reliable at driving
around office parks and what we're doing
here is we're navigating around an
office box so what you're seeing is
people trying to navigate from here
around the loop in the combo office back
to here
or around that sign or something yeah
halfway it's good too but yeah avoid the
walls walls are bad so if you watch you
know if you're watching at home if you
hit a wall it's back
they're saying they don't really hear
the people up front I guess I can get
closer
[Music]
everyone gets open gym
yeah we drove to the bathroom on its own
yes
um you can check out my code open source
now though
are you gonna demo yours as well George
does it work with all lighting
conditions
or we'll find out at night it did a full
autonomous Loop that's all I know
all right guys thanks for joining me
thanks for participating with me I met a
lot of cool people here I'm having a
great time
and I want to show you guys what I came
up with so this is Leon
Napoleon as uh I got a sign and we've
been having a great time needing
Napoleon uh he became my my good buddy
he follows me around he gives me space
when I need it he records when I need
him to and he's my companion so I'm
gonna take him for a tour around the
office
the wing the way Napoleon works is he
just finds the biggest person in his
field of view and evolves that person
around that and so that person sorry is
going to be me
and we're gonna go for a walk
I'm going to set him up
and
yeah let's do this
now while we make our way through here
try and not make yourself look big
just just for this one part the rest the
other week will be just fine but
a little bit
hey boy
good morning buddy
okay just like you practice all right
okay we're gonna go around here don't be
shy don't be shy just follow me yeah
just ignore them ignore them yeah we got
this let's go let's go that's right
[Laughter]
let's go
that's what I'm talking about guys eye
contact don't even no no
not your head
come on this way
over here
I'm going to give you a little hand just
because there we go all right
I'm big I'm little I'm big come on
oh my gosh
I should have worn my hoodie all right
here we go yeah now we're now we're out
of the trouble Zone
look how small I am
hey
let's go you follow me
touch that
perfect
peace
thank you
right here perfect
that's right all right now this way
go would you like to see
a little bit
looking up on me this way
we're gonna go straight shots okay let's
go
upstairs
almost home
all right if a loop great thanks
Napoleon good job
[Applause]
we've got a good number of people in the
Stream now
welcome everyone who's new
just had two of the teams present who is
next to we have
someone's time to be next is anyone
ready yeah you ready let's let's do it
we're ready
it's sitting right there
um yeah
uh
yeah
and somebody says quality equals
potatoes
um
foreign
[Music]
Instagram
and I'll also built a little bit to Aid
with the grain of course a bit of
um so you still have to just because
um number of DC client is a little bit
hold it slow wait like actual telnet
yeah yeah no they can like so I could
start by the way oh yeah
I got my I got my 28 8 modem
yeah
but it's pretty pretty useful because
right now we can uh basically just uh do
we started when you know around so
basically we gave the comments and I
recorded all data and automatically
labels
some but also we got a little bit
running also added like run mode and
step mode so run mode is basically just
runs bronze influence in Step mode is
basically a Transit ones and then follow
this for the common and it's another
influencing so on uh and also we can uh
in the real time send it even when it is
foreign
um
that's okay it's a little bit slow but
mostly because
cool
okay that's our presentation
[Applause]
did you want to do a demo as well you
want
you can do the sharks
advanced
foreign
all right there it goes
you know I guess return is left
it actually
sometime
[Laughter]
is it gonna get stuck
[Music]
but we'll give it one more attempt if it
hits the wall again we'll have to
see if Todd has recovered
it's a little box
don't do it I know it's tempting bro
you know
and thoughts are real slow and steady
conservative I'll come get the next
checkpoint at least yeah well let's see
what it does to this checkpoint
you know so the difference with the
hitting the wall is the other two runs
the bodies were covered if it recovers
on its own that's fine I don't think it
would recover once it installed yeah
yeah no I was answering there's a
comment about something yeah
yeah no we missed that check mark let's
let's cut it there all right let's go to
the next one if you have a hand for uh
anyone volunteering hello
yeah you guys all right let's do it
all right and remember to talk towards
the camera
so I can hear you
it's been a long weekend
this team's got Clay Thompson
is
oh you guys are running the other way
yeah we're going backwards right we've
got a backswords team what was the
reason for that yeah
oh you guys didn't like the infrared
camera view or are you guys using the
narrow cam
no we use the white one just wait
they're the exact same uh no no
everything looks red no sure but they
said it was disgusting look here but
they said it wasn't the IR
just like look at the camera and put
like purple cameras I kind of like the
rare one more the other one can see it
nice yeah I think it works better at
night because the lighting's consistent
I'm cold
Edgar then oh sorry guys one sec there's
a comment that says if we flip it it'll
sound a lot better let's try that
yeah
yeah rotates
okay
foreign
[Music]
learning approach we're using the
efficient net model
the initial starting out we tried to
hard code the path because that seemed
quite easy
what we learned a challenge was two
things one there's a lot of latency on
the office uh internet and so that skews
the commands that we're actually sending
to the robot and uh basically caused it
to go off course after that we quickly
corrected and moved towards a end-to-end
neural network
and I'll let Edgar talk about the
training how he collected the data and
then uh
fantastic oh uh so we basically try to
like to
um we'll label the data set will I carry
the robot like along the way so it's
like facing left gonna try to correct it
so it goes back to the right side and
um we try to like to control it with uh
with the joystick in like this way label
data set but it was kind of worse
because we had a lot of majority of the
class being just go forward so we ended
up just like having uh like face making
robot like face left carried forward and
make it the left class and just do the
sample riding forward so this way it
kind of had like balanced data but
training
um but for the training is pretty like
simple just efficient that'd be zero
will resize like input to 224 so have
like great scale images to fed the
network and we tried a bunch of
augmentations like dropping out like
changing saturation like contrast stuff
like that some you know and yeah it kind
of made it a little better so that's
pretty much like
the the training part yeah
yeah I guess just the last stuff
a few minutes I'm like kind of cool
features to help with testing and
iteration like engage disengage buttons
um fast loading without having to
restart the
color
and oh yeah and then loading the model
on the device to get around latency
issues
all right yeah the model's running on
the device yeah so we are running uh
natively on the device we took the Onyx
model and then converted it to the
thneed format which is allows us to use
the GPU of the comma and so let's switch
back to here we go through the stream
yeah so yeah I just started the model
and then I wanted to press the CNE Keys
yeah we added like two extra keys in the
monitor you can see the ENC basically
when I'm like debugging like if I press
the E and then the AI like engages and
like we press the C and these engages oh
it's kind of like convenient I have to
switch the camera
uh we we swapped the web app to use a
different stream yeah I mean it's pretty
easy to do that
it has recovery though it has recovery
oh it has recovered yeah
it should do something soon all right
okay
yeah
nice short turn oh solid
no things getting a little funky but
YouTube says you're the best team yet
oh it was fine just give it a Time
okay
nice nice
why doesn't just do it right the first
time
good question
oh solid wow
that's not kind of the tricky part
because we had all the data pretty
balanced but it still like has a bias or
the left side so yeah you multiply the
right probability by 1.1
it goes to the gym yeah
switch off the gym on YouTube it wants
to go to the gym all right I'll show the
gym
all right let's give it a chance to
recover
y
while we remember this is over there all
right
well well Clay is hanging out I mean
he's got a basketball jersey on clearly
where he wants to be is the comma gym we
have weights
and bigger waves and a treadmill
at the comma gym where clay wants to be
I think it's
yeah let's call it all right that's what
we made it to
him
[Applause]
more like a video yeah
does it sound better turned around guys
all right who's next all right yeah
let's do it
can we use your laptop yes okay wait I'm
just gonna do a quick check of who's
left
[Music]
three three left after the current team
ready
okay they say it's better
you just can't wait
so I'm sleeping and dead over there yeah
yeah no he's uh he's had a fun past few
days so
um but yeah our team was none other than
the great Julius Caesar in the flesh or
in the metal I guess
um and then our approach we tried a
whole bunch of different things but what
we settled on doing was doing an
end-to-end model but instead of just
using the like raw colored data we do a
depth estimation with just an
off-the-shelf Network and then do end to
end on the depth destination
um we originally wanted to just do kind
of like a traditional 2D slam with the
depth estimation so you could take like
a horizontal slice or something like
that and then map out the building
um but that was you know less trivial
than we thought it was
um so we ended up just kind of doing
this end to end so you can see the
real-time color video there on the left
and then the depth here
um and then we just kind of run that
through the model uh we kind of did the
normal ends and training routine where
you you know get some good training
examples where it's kind of facing
forward somewhere you carry it and it's
like facing left somewhere you carry it
and it's facing right and that works
like decently well uh we were able to
get from like checkpoint zero to
checkpoint one uh somewhat consistently
maybe it'll struggle with all these
people in the room we'll see but since
we have the depth data there's a lot of
potential for augmentations and stuff so
you can take the depth and you know
where you're facing and then you can
translate the camera to the left to the
right and do all these things like this
so here's kind of a demo of that it's
also invariant to the time of day yes so
that's another big benefit is that lots
of people struggled where like they get
all their training data at night and it
doesn't work in the day the idea here is
like you know the depth estimator is
trained on the daytime and nighttime in
the
So This Is Us trying to augment the data
so we took one picture and then we're
using the depth data projecting it into
3D moving the camera and then
reprojecting it back into that a little
bit like the
that's a little bit of some issues no
need to talk no need to point it out too
tidy for me to see from all the way back
there yes exactly
um
[Laughter]
it's familiar yeah it looks familiar
yeah
uh sadly we're not so since we're
running two models we're like almost
like really you know causing this GPU to
struggle so moving it on to device is
definitely doable but we just haven't
done it yet
okay all right should we demo it and
then the model itself uh for our end to
end is just a resnet 50 and then the
depth estimator is just like the top
desktop estimator on hooking face so is
this a demo yeah here we go
all right well
a good start
yeah we'll see yeah it's never seen this
many people before though
oh
all right recovery no no recovery okay
so we'll standardize One manual recovery
yeah one manual recovery
is containment all right
when it's more confident it goes faster
yeah
[Music]
that's it for Julius Caesar
all right
well that's given up for that team
[Applause]
thank you
right then we've got uh three more teams
yeah go ahead
did you want to reset that cone outside
making it outside when I'm here
ambitious
they'll just be selling the code oh okay
yeah okay
to capture
yeah
remember to talk loud yes
okay your team Spike the biker I'm Ellen
I'm Maria and I'm ammo
yeah and so
um we have a symptom
and we train in simulation and blender
and then use the PID trajectories to
follow the line the desired Center PATH
more closely and then use that to train
a division net classifier to then
predict the action based on images and
then
yeah and so what we started by by doing
is like mapping the office so we use the
the iPhone lighter to get a 3D scan and
as well as the floor plan
and then from that we train a simple PID
to get the to get some trajectories so
yeah that's the blender project we did
import like basically just a quick scan
with lidar and then I tried to add some
artificial lights that basically at the
same spot but you guys
play the play the keyframes yeah
looks like this and there is also an
animation it's like a main
okay so that's the kind of trajectories
that we created maybe you want to
explain how we made it yeah just a
simple PID following the line and so
then we just put those trajectories into
blender and move the camera around and
then from those images we predict the
output of the PID which is just the
steering to the robot and that's uh yeah
that's basically it and try to show the
images yeah just the PID is like
uh
basically we took the floor plan and we
drove a path and then we tune a PID to
follow it and then yeah using this
matching with blender we match like a
pair of images in action I'm trying to
see another
yeah
should we go forward
no the filtering as well it was also
kind of difficult to get good trajectory
using on your PID we initially wanted to
train some reinforcement learning but it
was a bit too short and so what we ended
up trying to do is uh can we go to the
Future go back uh oh yeah that's that's
important that's we matched the images
in blender to the images from the camera
obviously that's okay that's a simulated
picture it's like a symmetic picture but
so it has blender on top of the actual
real image it's like to compare the the
images
so yeah so we like use the camera
calibration and worked the images to
match the the fisheye of the the camera
yeah and then we also have augmentations
for the actual image so like color
tinting and everything so it looks ends
up looking really similar you have a
picture of it just a full simulator
um
uh you know what I'm saying right just
the screenshot of a simulated frame with
all the oh like matching augmentation
and stuff yeah
I didn't see blender of the fisheye like
realistically yeah basically yeah that's
the issue we do it like after blender
also for like compute reason because
it's too slow in blender and also like
we don't know what mother they use
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
so with blender we could sample all my
introductions we have 200 000 images and
and we also sample uh along like in
different locations kind of skewed away
from the path and have it conjoined back
to the path and then we stop it so
um actually we should have had the
distribution of the other predicted
actions but most of the time it's
predicting left and right because we
don't want it to be following the path
and that's not very useful so we stop it
after a certain amount of time and then
we have it sample a different location
and the PID to get a lot of their
introductory so it can recover quite
well you don't see the demo yeah yeah
cool okay
yeah they already did yeah
oh yeah
they want to know if it's all running on
the device
so far
oh you recovered
it was closed on the simulation
like the simulation
YouTube says you guys got off to a very
clean start
yeah I hope it stays that way yeah
the gym seems to be the next checkpoint
yeah yeah
we have often tempted to go to the gym
too
oh my God
I think let's hang out here because it
cuts out around the bathrooms and then
if it goes around
we'll go there
oh
nice okay
oh it's gonna turn
um
no no so passing the X isn't bad the X's
are just checkpoints
he just wants to go back inside
all right nice job Spike
[Applause]
congratulations
YouTube agrees yeah
all right nice work so we got two more
teams
uh Chad pietti are we good to go
um
yeah I think if you change code after
other people have presented it's it's
it's not a good not a good uh oh man
yeah
[Music]
yeah but remember how shameful it's
going to be if you don't know
maybe you want to drive it up a little
bit
yeah
just a quick close-up let's get a good
look at him right there
all right I'm moving back now
all right everyone YouTube this has been
swallow here my name is John this is
James he's actually off screen so I'll
move oh
yeah yeah I can explain the training so
basically what we did to
um set up Ben's Polo here is we captured
frames by driving around the office
using just the wastd keys and then
matching the frame with the key at that
actual timing and then we used that to
train our fine-tune resnet so if I go to
the
be here if you can see
um we processed some of the images
and then
basically fine-tuned the model from
there we didn't collect end up
collecting enough data because I wanted
to use visual language models and we set
up blip 2 on our AWS instance previously
but it ended up not working and who's
really hallucinating a lot so we ended
up going with this method but we didn't
collect a lot of data so it's probably
going to just crash into this wall here
so let's see maybe we had a couple runs
where it was all right but
the one thing that we did do that a lot
of teams didn't use is we used canny to
filter out any possible issues with
color so it'll work both at night and in
day well it can crash into walls in Fall
of nights
all right uh the other thing that we did
that I don't believe anyone else is
doing we're actually running our code in
AWS which is getting streamed down to
the device here through tailscale tail
scale is like a mesh VPN solution so you
can just install it on any device you
want and it just boom networks them
together you don't have to worry about
anything so hopefully the internet is
stable enough and it all works so
without further Ado let's uh give you a
demo and show you what Ben swallow can
do
yeah the stream and AWS are going to be
competing in this run
bandwidth we don't need to really have
our workstations are genuinely 10
gigabit
I swallow going straight to the bench
press
[Laughter]
to get to the gym
we did this originally when there were
good
we did this originally when there were a
lot of food tables here so the training
data start start after the food Tails
we'll start after the food tables
all right
for the entertainment about it it's so
fast
all right I missed the checkpoint
oh
all right
[Applause]
everything
chapter it's gonna be tough guys
um let me just be curious
um okay
you don't have to do it I mean yeah
thank you
that's why it's like kind of nice
as you can see oh you want to see where
I did actually I did it right here
oh my gosh so um cursor
um all right
yes chat PID I guess llm's doing
controls
um it's kind of the future I don't think
you guys so I can see the the English
you should
yeah so
um basically I'm doing Sam but I guess
I'm dumb and I didn't know there was a
mobile version so I'm actually running
it in a a100 on modal
um
that would have been nice to know
yeah so PID is like a dollar a second or
so
uh yeah just to go through really quick
so you're on the camera
camera uh we get this image and then we
run Sam but Sam doesn't label so I have
a heuristic labeler which is actually
the first image
um that just gets floors and walls based
on how big it is and then and then it
works yeah see how does it tell you the
class
it totally tells you the class no it
doesn't it's the colors
it doesn't tell you what it is though it
doesn't say floor just do it like green
or something that's what I did that's
what I did anyways
this is good though so this is the floor
and then walls and then uh Blues other
stuff and then and then we get this and
then we get a really nice ASCII
and then we feed this ASCII into chat
gbt so
um
yeah it's always my cursor
um and the prompts like pretty pretty
nice
yeah yeah we give you some of the
prompts though
you're a self-driving model and body
does a five foot tall two-wheeled robot
I get here I can show you the ASCII logs
so I give it it's like the floor this is
its current location I have like a top
left just so it kind of knows what's
going on
um and yes this is what it sees holy
[__]
um
yeah well anyways let's see what it does
I guess let's see what it does so screw
and running we'll see in the bottom here
what it's thinking I guess
um
there you go okay so it wants to do oh
wait it's
okay this is the first this should be
the first one I think so we're running
out
[Music]
so you can see
so it looks pretty good right the
control loops like roughly 0.01 Hertz
so
[Music]
it's a plan so the plan last time was to
move forward slightly adjust to the left
stick to the left side of the track
continue to move forward micro
adjustments
uh yeah what do you do you drive down
cars yeah dude
can you yell at it when GPD doesn't
follow the right structure it just goes
backwards
so we got Linda list the next out of
range can we can we get him to at least
recover from going into the wall how
long is that gonna take let's let's
let's wait another 30 seconds
what is that ninety dollars
um there's actually an a100 thinking
about this problem
I can see it think right here
that's my a100 bill
the numbers are crunching Chinese
this is
to extract most money
[Laughter]
oh yeah
thank you
it's kind of here
all right thanks again for uh
I guess
um
uh I spent 50 on modeling 100 on G4
did you want to demo yours or uh I can
try I don't think it's as good blender
can't beat me I don't see it if you can
try it
all right George has a solution too that
we're gonna stop some people holding the
thing like this like they're walking up
against the last wall so I shamelessly
copied their strategy
um it was like with engineering prowess
and pre uh existing knowledge of the
comma code base uh maybe I can win
um it's open source right now on my
GitHub under body Loop
I also put it in speed mode for maximum
entertainment
so uh we're gonna see I'm just connected
into the body here let's go in here's
the first one to do
yeah so just here it is it's you know
yeah it's called common body Loop driver
I did all the training and inference in
tiny grad
um the thing that I'm most proud of
is that I have control dot i and control
dot Pi can run seamlessly either on the
device or on the computer and it'll Loop
it nicely on the computer or it'll just
run locally on the device I didn't have
to use the need
I just use the tiny jet so I collected a
data set yeah
maybe I'll show you like what the data
set looks like
um
so like this is an example of when
you're too far to the right
you just recorded this data what labels
do you have is just like I just labeled
the entire video this is a right video
there's left videos and write videos
here I can show you a left video
uh
for comparison
how many videos
um so I gathered lots of videos and then
I actually got it to drive the entire
Loop once during the day and once at
night
um every time it would mess up I would
just record a mess up video
um so I can show you what these mess up
videos look like like this is my data
set here
so we can look at like mess up one the
massive video is also going to be like
one class or mess of videos are just one
class this is a mess up where you should
be going more right
see so like if it's over there you
should be going right all right let's
see if this works
did you clip the mess-ups to where they
should have done something else yeah it
makes sense so I put it in maximum speed
mode we got to compile the uh the model
here
very smooth
uh
could not acquire media permission
denied
I missed the checkpoint
all right
all right let's go Jeff
's got no interest in the gym whatsoever
we'll give them one more
oh let's go Jeff
I Jeff want to take a quick leak
[Music]
see if he does it
oh no
I'll give it more recovery initial
you can do the turn
nope all right he wants to go back
[Music]
so close all right let's carry him in
too Speedy
all right YouTube voted Jeff a second
[Laughter]
he's designed to go but he's less
entertaining and I guess we'll see how
this goes too
it should work a lot better at this
speed I don't know why I went for the
high speed
[Laughter]
[Music]
I did yeah I did I did both of my
complete Loops at this speed
[Music]
see now it didn't actually make that
turn yeah
didn't know what for the high speed
see if he's interested in the gym now no
no
you really misses all the X's
oh no sometimes he goes that way
oh corrected
oh my correct yourself
he doesn't like axes
I tried to train a generic model that
would go like anyway yeah so the problem
with that is sometimes it goes that way
I thought it wasn't too bad last time
yeah we'll do it this time
you can present Mitchell
no Jeff
y stop
what's up Jeff
Drive during the day
I am avoid obstacles so
thank you
all right let's go back inside and uh
I think we're gonna end the stream and
then we'll deliberate him with some
judging all right and uh we'll tweet a
picture on uh on our Twitter of the who
will decide the winners are
George is not eligible foreign
so by a comma 3x it'll ship Monday back
on 3x
bye everyone
[Music]
bye-bye